in awkward case of nepotism fights with
writers and directors and alcohol-fueled
subterfuge or just some of the stunning
details in these stories of actors being
unceremoniously replaced in the 2013
science fiction romance her Joaquin
Phoenix plays a man named Theodore who
is struggling to let go of his ex-wife
and commit to another person so he
downloads a personal assistant program
outfitted with an artificial
intelligence named Samantha and their
relationship evolves into something
deeper as she evolves her own
programming during filming Phoenix had a
real-life Samantha to deliver his lines
to in the form of Samantha Morton but
when director Spike Jones got to the
editing room in post-production he
realized that the movie needed something
else so he ended up recasting Samantha
Scarlett Johansson this required four
extra months of recording sessions for
Phoenix and it doesn't sound like he was
happy about that as he told the Los
Angeles Times about Morton she was my
partner she was always in my head she
created Theodore as much as I did as
Marty's dad George McFly Crispin Glover
was an essential piece of the first Back
to the Future then for the two sequels
you was replaced by Jeffrey Weissman in
the years since Glover said that his
quibbles with the ending of the original
film anger director Robert zemeckis as
the actor explained to den of geek in
2013 I thought it was not a good idea
for our characters to have a monetary
reward because it basically makes the
moral of the movie that money equals
happiness Glover also said that producer
and co-writer Bob Gale inaccurately
claimed that he has to be paid as much
as Michael J fox for part two according
to Glover the problem was that he was
being offered less than half as much as
his co-stars Leah Thompson and Tom
Wilson whatever the actual reason for
the switch Thompson wasn't exactly happy
about it in the book we don't need
Rhodes the making of the Back to the
Future Trilogy she called Glover a bit
of a handful but as she also noted you
definitely got your money's worth
Weissman actually wore a latex face mold
to look more like Glover and he claimed
that his fellow actors barely bothered
to learn his name Thompson even referred
to him as the guy playing crispit Glover
would later win a settlement from
Universal for using his likeness without
his permission now Beth don't con me
changing directors often leads to castry
shuffle and when the 2015 Pixar flick
the good dinosaur replaced Bob Peterson
with Peterson that spelled pink slips
for most of the voice cast son decided
that he needed to find a younger actor
for the main character of Arlo so he
replaced 29 year old Lucas Neff with 13
year old Raymond Ochoa as soon explained
to Yahoo everything else all the other
characters that supported that story
came in and out and changed and evolved
and threw that Evolution some of those
performers changed out of it in addition
to Neff Sone also sent Neil Patrick
Harris John Lithgow Bill Hader and Judy
Greer packing Lithgow said that he
expected to be re-recording some of his
dialogue following the change in
director so clearly he didn't expect to
be cut out entirely soon ultimately
stood by his decision as he explained to
the independent it's a tough thing but I
believe everything we had done in the
previous version helped us out
1999's the mummy is an action-adventure
classic but at the time it was a
surprise hit that cemented Brendan
Fraser and Rachel vice's places in
Hollywood the pair would go on to return
in 2001 for the first sequel The Mummy
Returns then the next sequel Tomb of the
Dragon Emperor didn't arrive until 2008
and when it did it was missing Vice as
John Hannah who played vice's brother in
the series explained in an interview
with the Scotsman that was a pretty
Hollywood moment I couldn't really
figure out how Jonathan would be in it
if Rachel wasn't it never occurred to me
that they just recast it Hannah also
claimed that Vice was initially on board
for Tomb of the Dragon Emperor and
filming was delayed when she had a baby
but then something happened and she was
replaced with Maria Bello Fraser
soldiered on with a new version of his
wife but as he told collider I felt
Rachel's absence when I read the
screenplay the first time we were
Partners we were colleagues we were
friends and I couldn't read the
screenplay and not think about hearing
her say it this way or that way we had
that chemistry things got ugly when
director Rob Cohen claimed that vice's
Vanishing Act was due to her character
now being a mother to an older son
something that she's denied but I wish
you would do it sooner rather than later
before you ruin my career the way you
ruined yours
1967's pill popping Hollywood skewering
Camp classic Valley of the Dolls was
based on the novel of the same name by
Jacqueline Suzanne who modeled her
characters on actual Show Business
personalities a couple of her characters
were based on such Legends as Ethel
Merman and Judy Garland sticking close
to the book's gossipy Roots Garland was
originally cast in the film as aging
stage star Helen while Patty Duke played
the part of kneeling as duke recalled in
a 2009 interview I worshiped her she
made me laugh every time she looked at
me but just a couple days into the shoot
Garland was unceremoniously fired at the
command of director Mark Robson as duke
recalled she had to come in at 6 30 in
the morning Angie wouldn't even plan to
get to her until four in the afternoon
according to Duke during this wait
Garland was plied with wine and other
things so that she wouldn't be able to
function properly on set she was
ultimately replaced by Susan Hayward and
the entire Valley of the doll's crew was
upset about this rather unfortunate turn
of events
one of the most infamous cast
Replacements in cinema history happened
in 1990 with the highly anticipated
Godfather Part 3. its two predecessors
are among the most beloved films of all
time so the expectations were naturally
High adding to the pressure was the
pivotal casting of Mary Corleone the
daughter of Al Pacino's Michael the
character proved much harder to cast
than anticipated the room at First
Choice of Julia Roberts reportedly left
for apart in flatliners while Madonna
also read for the role but was deemed
too mature most tragically Rebecca
Schaefer was murdered on the morning of
her audition ultimately Winona Ryder was
cast and flew to Rome for filming
shortly after rapping mermaids
unfortunately she became ill from
exhaustion and exited on the advice of a
doctor this left the production
scrambling to find a new Mary several
weeks into filming director Francis Ford
Coppola ultimately ended up casting his
own 19 year old daughter Sophia it was
reported that this didn't sit well with
the cast who allegedly took issue with
what they saw as nepotism an extra was
quoted saying to Entertainment Weekly
she couldn't pronounce the name Corleone
her father had to keep cutting and
retaking the scene she was in over her
head Tony says that I'm a front for the
foundation
that you're using me just to pull the
strings
The Silence of the Lambs is quite the
Rarity among Oscar Best Picture winners
it was a bloody genre flick that won
over General audiences just as much as
it did the often stodgy voters of the
academy plus it was based on just one
book in his series by author Thomas
Harris so another gory psychological
Thriller starring Anthony Hopkins as
Hannibal Lecter was undoubtedly on the
table and so Hannibal went into
production in 2000 with Hopkins on board
to reprice his iconic oscar-winning role
but not so eager for rehash was his
fellow oscar-winning co-star Jody Foster
who decided against returning as FBI Ace
Clary Starling as reported by the
guardian she objected to the sequel's
premise which found her character
brainwashed by Hannibal and joining him
in feasting on human flesh the script
was Rewritten to get around those plot
elements but at that point Foster was
still saying no a source close to
Hopkins told the guardian that he was
absolutely furious with Foster's actions
while her lack of Interest initially
threw the entire production into
question it was saved when Julian Moore
agreed to step in his Clarisse it's
still one of the most famous such a
rules in television history suddenly
some guy who wasn't York was playing
Darren Stevens on the classic sitcom
Bewitched the show also starred Agnes
Moorhead as the Witch and Dora mother to
the main witch Samantha played by
Elizabeth Montgomery and Dora cared so
little for her son-in-law Darren that
she never got his name right and I want
to thank you for your compliment Darwin
Darren in reality though Moorhead
reportedly really liked Dick York but
when health problems forced him to leave
the show in 1969 producers brought in
another dick and Dick Sergeant took over
the part as if nothing had happened but
Moorhead was furious at Sergeant's first
table read she reportedly stood up and
shouted I am not fond of change Sergeant
later revealed that Moorhead also said
while he was an earshot they should
never meddle with success Sergeant took
that to Maine Dick York should never
have been replaced which I thought was a
very cruel and unthinking thing to say
in front of me The Honeymooners a
landmark sitcom about a working class
Brooklyn couple famously ran for just
139 episode season on CBS from 1955 to
1956 but before they had their own show
bus driver Ralph Kramden and his acerbic
wife Alice were featured in a series of
comedy sketches first on the Dumont
Network's Cavalcade of stars in 1951 and
then the Jackie Gleason Show on CBS the
following year
[Music]
the earliest Dumont shorts are a little
different from what fans of the show
might remember Ralph and Alice's
relationship is more fraught Art Carney
appears as a policeman in the first
short rather than as neighbor sidekick
Ed Norton and Alice is played by Bert
Kelton gelton was a Vaudeville trained
performer with a film career stretching
back to the 1920s but when Jackie
Gleason moved his operation from Dumont
to CBS in 1952 he wasn't allowed to
bring her along the reason had nothing
to do with the quality of her
performance and everything to do with
the politics of the time in 1950 Kelton
and her husband actor Ralph Bell were
named in the book red channels a
compendium of alleged Communists working
in the entertainment industry despite
having little to no official political
affiliations at the time Kelton was
blacklisted by CBS much to Gleason's
Chagrin he initially refused to consider
any other actress to play Alice but he
eventually relented and recast the part
first with ginger Jones for a touring
live show and then with Audrey Meadows
who made the role famous on The Jackie
Gleason Show and then on The
Honeymooners the official line for
departure was that she had chronic
health issues
one of the most notorious flops in
television history was 1976's The Brady
Bunch variety hour produced by Sid and
Marty Croft it reunited the cast of The
Brady Bunch for a weekly hour of singing
dancing and comedy the only problem was
that with the exception of Florence
Henderson none of the original cast was
all that Adept at singing or dancing or
sketch comedy this show was a train
wreck right from the start and lasted
just Nine episodes Susan Olsen who
played baby sister Cindy and co-wrote a
book about the disastrous series put it
bluntland in 2009 interview and she said
it was a spectacular turd not every
member of The Brady cast was quite so
willing to make a fool of himself though
former Jan Brady star Eve Plum declined
to join the variety hour fearing the
possibility of getting locked into a
multi-year contract the humorous
concerned in hindsight in order to keep
the symmetry of three sons and three
daughters the show brought in a new Jan
in the form of Jerry Rochelle who has
since become somewhat affectionately
known as fake Jam many in the cast were
disappointed that Plum didn't come back
especially Olson who had grown up beside
her for five years on The Brady Bunch as
she recalled I was happy for her and I
was jealous of her because she was
moving on
[Music]